The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
ORY ZIK: Thank you.
It's a pleasure to be here.
So I'm going to talk
about Greenometry.
Greenometry is a new nonprofit
that enlists the market
in solving climate change.
Enlisting the
market means that we
want to allow everyone
to know the carbon
footprint of everything.
And for that, we need
to fix carbon footprint.
So that's what I
want to talk about.
And it's not a secret
to you that the country
took like a different
trajectory than reality.
16 of the last 17 years
were the hottest on record.
And then policy is going
on the opposite direction.
So if we would expect the
emitters, the supply side,
to be a major part
of the solution,
they have less incentive to be
a major part of the solution
right now because
they're not forced to.
So the power that we want
to engage is the market.
And if you think
about it, the market
is maybe the largest
force on the planet.
Think about nearly 7
billion buyers, trillions
of dollars of investors.
About 400 companies control
70% of the commodity trading.
Think about the decision
power these entities have.
Universities, every
university, including this one,
has a climate action plan.
Cities, about 70% of the
carbon emission on the planet
is related to cities and so on.
So we want to engage the market.
The oxygen of
markets is metrics.
Markets need to
be run by numbers.
And the problem is that
carbon footprint is broken.
The system doesn't add up.
If I would ask any of you what
the carbon footprint of nearly
anything, you wouldn't know.
It's so vague.
So we need to fix
carbon footprint
to activate the market to
be part of the solution.
And I want to talk
more about this point.
So if you look at
how many searches
are done for the term
carbon footprint on Google,
you would see the rise and
fall of carbon footprint.
It was high and then went low.
If you look at newspaper
articles, it also went lower.
On the other hand, academic
publications went up.
So there's a gap between
knowledge and actual public
engagement in the actual
information of what
is a carbon footprint.
And part of the
mission of Greenometry,
in order to allow everyone
to know the carbon
footprint of
everything, is to bridge
this gap between knowledge
and actual behavior.
So what makes a good metric?
So how do we build a
good carbon footprint?
To answer this question,
a few years ago,
I went to meet Daniel
Kahneman, the Nobel Prize
winner in Economics.
And we had a long conversation
about what makes a good metric.
And essentially you need
to think of two components.
One is simplicity.
It needs to be simple.
We need to be able
to make estimations,
to make back-of-the-envelope
quantitative reasoning.
And you need accuracy.
In most decisions in
life, we use this ability
to make estimations.
We estimate distances.
We estimate price.
We estimate the
probability that the jury
will be more in our favor.
We do those estimations
all the time.
Someone on a diet
can estimate calories
with pretty good accuracy.
If you like sports,
then you would
know that an Olympic
athlete will run
100 meters at about 10 seconds.
But then you need
the accuracy in order
to have a race to the top.
Who is the best?
It's fractions of seconds.
And if you think
about carbon footprint
and you want to compare two
products that are the same,
two running shoes,
you need the accuracy
in order to determine
between the two of them.
So you need simplicity,
and you need accuracy.
The simplicity is this
quantitative reasoning
or quantitative intuition,
which is sort of vague or sort
of elusive.
But quantitative
intuition, the way
to build it, according to
this beautiful book, Thinking
of Fast and Slow, is by thinking
about two things, practice
and consistency.
If you have a consistent signal,
like the calories of food,
and you think about it
daily, it becomes intuitive.
So how well are we doing
on carbon footprint?
And the easiest thing to think
about is a gallon of gas.
This is like the
one major decision
that we really make
daily, put gas in our car.
It's very energy dense, and this
is like the largest emission
that we do.
And about two hours
a year, we have
nothing better to do, just fuel
our cars and look at the price.
That's why the
price is presented
with fractions of cents.
So how well can we tell
the carbon content,
how much the carbon
emission of a gallon of gas?
So we were curious
about this question.
And with a friend at
Northeastern University,
we've asked 300 people, how much
carbon they emit when they put
one gallon of gas in their car?
The variation of the answer
was two to three orders
of magnitude between
grams and tons,
sort of, or tens
of grams of tons.
Think about going into
a Starbucks wanting
to buy a cup of
coffee and don't know
if it's going to cost
you $300 or 0.3 cents.
That's how bad we are.
So what does the market
have to fix this problem?
If we look at numbers in an
anecdotal way, it's adjectives.
Grams, tons,
everything is confused.
It's either that we
don't care, or that we're
too lazy to actually
do the math,
or something else is wrong in
the system that we want to fix.
By the way, we were so
surprised by this result,
that we asked 1,000 people
and got the same result.
This is a log scale.
The x-axis are
questions that are also
relevant to the daily life, like
what's the weight of the car?
You don't lift your car.
And still it's orders of
magnitude better estimation
than carbon.
Something is fundamentally
wrong with carbon footprint.
If you put the same data in
different carbon calculators
online, the result
varies by 300%.
So MIT wants to reduce its
carbon footprint by, let's say,
30%.
And we use a system with
uncertainty of 300%.
So where is the math?
And that obviously gives rise
to all kinds of anecdotes.
We can see newspaper articles
about saving the planet
by sending less emails
because an email is 0.3 grams.
And in the world of anecdotes
of adjectives, a gram and a ton
is the same.
So you don't bother
to do the math.
It's 0.00003 a
gallon of gas, right?
If you look at the
way that companies
are handling this problem,
look at Timberland.
Timberland is probably
one of the companies
that were the best geared to
have a good sustainability
program.
They had a committed CEO,
committed shareholders.
The customers are
the outdoor people.
So it's better.
So they wanted to reduce
their carbon footprint.
And they built great
sustainability reports.
They were prize winners in
terms of the sustainability
performance.
The way carbon
footprint is built,
so they looked at
only their own site
emissions, what they're
responsible for,
which turns out to be about
4% of the total emission.
The other about
20% is electricity,
and then the rest
is supply chain.
So they did phenomenal work
reducing 20% of the 4%.
And that's the best company.
And then they said, let's
engage our customers,
our outdoor people.
So they had a label, a
product label on the shoes.
An average Timberland shoe
is about two kilowatt hour.
The accuracy was such
that all the shoes
were two kilowatt hour.
And who is the
consumer that knows
what's a kilowatt hour
in the context of a shoe?
What buying decisions it make?
So after 18 months of
building this program,
they had the label,
and they took it out.
So something is fundamentally
wrong with the way
we try to fix the
problem of climate change
through the market because the
market doesn't have metrics,
because carbon
footprint doesn't work.
So let's look at how
carbon footprint is built.
What are we doing?
So it's divided to a few scopes.
Scope one is what we do on site.
Scope two is the electricity
that we purchase.
And it's divided to scope
to avoid a double counting.
Then supply chain
is hugely complex.
It is scope 3.
It is complex
because how do I know
what the supply in China or
in Vietnam or in Malaysia
is doing, and how do I
allocate their emissions
to the different
other customers?
And then there are things
that are really important
and are not included,
like water or land use.
Next step is to convert this
consumption to a metric, which
is tons of CO2.
And then we need to
read the tons of CO2.
So what needs fixing?
The on-site emission
is pretty well.
We can measure it.
We can measure our natural gas,
that you'll hear about soon.
Everything that's on site is OK.
Electricity is a
very complex problem
because we need to solve
the inverse problem.
I'm here consuming
electricity in this room.
Some of it might come from the
co-gen plant down the road.
Some of it might come from New
England ISO, from solar panels,
from Hydro-Québec.
How do I solve this problem?
It's a problem that
wasn't solved yet.
Supply chain, as I
said, is hugely complex.
It needs to be fixed.
And then water
needs to be fixed.
And then I need a metric
which is intuitive.
So we won't talk
with those anecdotes.
So it's a hugely
complex system, because
agricultural and
gradual waste and where
everything comes from is--
solving for the infrastructure
is very complex.
And as I mentioned, we need
to solve the inverse problem.
We're in the end
receiving electricity.
And we need to work
out all the way
upstream to see where this
electricity is coming from.
And electricity is one example.
And the other problem is that
your generation is busy doing
something else, clicking ads.
The best data scientists
in this country
are busy doing not
solving social problems,
but solving other problem.
So part of the things that
we're doing with Greenometry
is just trying to build a
tech company, nonprofit,
nonprofit that acts
like a tech company.
But the success
criteria, instead
of being building
shareholder value,
it will be just abated CO2, just
reducing a carbon footprint.
So we want to fix the
electricity, the supply chain,
obviously with the others--
we cannot do everything
ourselves-- water, and
have a very simple unit,
which we call an energy point.
An energy point is simply 10
kilograms of CO2, very simple.
But it's equivalent
to one gallon of gas.
So if I bought a shoe that
is three energy points.
I know that it's equivalent
to about three gallons of gas
in my car, start
building this intuition.
And it's a huge path, and we're
in the beginning of this road
because creating a new
language, a new quantitative way
of thinking about
things is a huge path.
So let me show you a few
ways that we've handled
this problem with data science.
So thinking about
electricity, the carbon
footprint of electricity
is measured in this country
right now.
And the US, by the way,
is leading in the world.
And God bless the
EPA, and I hope
that they'll exist and
be safe for a long time.
So the EPA divides
the US to 24 regions,
provides an annual
average information,
with two years delay.
So just two weeks ago, we
got the 2014 information,
which is an annual average.
Now, as we know, electricity is
traded in 10 minutes intervals.
And there's about 20,000
power plants in the US.
So it's a hugely complex
problem that needs
to be solved with more details.
So we've developed a
data science model, where
we didn't solve it entirely.
We just improved it.
And then published and
made the data available.
We improved the cadence from
annual to monthly or hourly--
it depends on the data
available from the power
plants-- and the spatial
resolution from 24 to 138.
So it's progress.
And we're not providing this
information to all developers
through an API that will
be launched next week.
So every developer
that would like
to develop an app
that uses electricity
can use our information
and develop cool apps.
Because the developers
market is kind of
stagnant in carbon footprint
if the data is so boring
and in such a low cadence.
Another example of
solving carbon footprint
is how to introduce water
into carbon footprint.
So as someone who
grew up in Israel,
I'm very sensitive
to the water issue.
Just like you have
college football
in the newspaper in the US, you
have water issues in Israel,
along with other issues.
So the way we developed it, we
looked at the energy intensity
of water.
How much energy is invested
in water in each location?
And then what's the source
of this energy, which
is the previous problem?
And together we mapped
water into energy.
Now, there's a
huge remaining work
to do because it's very local.
Last summer farmers
in Massachusetts
had to truck water
into their fields.
How do you account for that?
How do you account for scarcity?
So what we do is we try
to solve this problem,
publish papers in academic
journals or other places,
engage into a dialogue.
So let's see how the world, if
we have this carbon footprint
2.0, if we have like
a quantitative way
to think about climate,
how the world looks like.
So think about the
possibility that each of you
will have a carbon budget.
In very simple terms, EP
equivalent to a gallon of gas,
as we've discussed.
So you have a household budget.
You have a city budget,
a university budget,
a company budget in your EP.
And you have a context.
If you're in Texas
in the summer,
it will be about 200 EPs,
equivalent to a gallon of gas,
or 2,000 kilos of CO2 per
month for your household.
And part of it is water
just because a lot of energy
goes into water.
In New England in the
winter will be less.
But it can be very specific.
And you start thinking
quantitatively
about your impact.
So if you have, just
like we've discussed,
a home energy device, so a home
energy device, like a sense,
will give you a reading
in kilowatt hours.
So we have, let's say,
29 kilowatt hours.
It doesn't have
any carbon context
unless you translate it to what
happens on the grid right now.
So using our API, you can
have this translation.
So you can see that
if I'm in Brookline
and I have in my
energy sources solar,
this 29 kilowatt hours
is less than 1 EP.
But on the other hand,
if I'm in Wyoming
and my electricity source
happens to be coal,
it can be significantly
more, maybe five times more.
So I can have a
budget that allows
me to think quantitatively.
Just like a diet, I
think about calories,
think about my carbon footprint.
If I happen to drive
a Tesla, so the Tesla
doesn't have an MPG
rating because it
doesn't consume gasoline.
But if you think about this
conversion of 10 kilograms
of CO2 is a gallon of gas,
so I can convert the same 10
kilograms of CO2 to
the energy sources that
feed the Tesla right now.
Instead of having
just watt hours
per mile, which is the reading
on the Tesla dashboard,
I can have the Tesla MPG.
So I can actually compare
the Tesla to other cars.
Tesla versus Lexus,
if I'm in Wyoming
and I have an
energy-intensive grid,
actually the Lexus is better.
If I'm in California,
most of California
or most of Massachusetts,
actually Tesla is better.
And if I have a cleaner power
source, obviously it's better.
But everything is quantitative.
It's not anecdotal.
It's the actions
actually add up.
So I can see how
much money I need
to invest per unit of carbon.
One of my favorite examples
is the running shoe.
If I buy and Nike, Nike is
very proud of the Flyknit
because they have
this great innovation
of having one thread that
ties the entire shoe.
But the Flyknit
reduces about 20%
of the material in the shoe,
which is a huge accomplishment.
But if you think about
the climate impact
and you add the energy
and water, which
are pretty similar to the
competing issue, the Pegasus,
the accomplishment
is not that huge.
It's like about, let's say, 10%.
What's interesting, especially
with those conversations
on domestic manufacturing,
is that if I
will know the entire
infrastructure,
I'll solve this reverse
problem and understand
the infrastructure, and
look at what does it
mean for the climate,
not financially?
To move manufracturing to
Portland, Oregon, Nike's
headquarter, I will reduce
the impact of these shoes
significantly, by about 30%,
because they have cleaner
water and cleaner power.
And I have this
quantitative notion.
I step into a shop, want
to buy a running shoe.
And I know that it's
about three energy
points, which is equivalent
to about three gallons of gas.
So I can know how much it
relates to my other activities.
I start having a budget.
Just like people
that are athletes
that run their
lives with a Fitbit,
I can have a "carbon bit."
There are endless possibilities.
And I'll end with the
last example, investors.
There are trillions
of dollars that
claim to be impact investors.
And they're thirsty for data.
For one example,
imagine that you want
to invest in a solar project.
Now, a solar project, if you
take a mono-silicon panels
produced in China, installed
in a relatively clean grid
in California, it can
take up to nine years just
to pay back the carbon.
If the lifetime of these panels
is 20 years, it's nearly half.
It's a serious time just
paying back the carbon.
So the MPG of solar using
Carbon Footprint 2.0
can be calculated.
On the other hand, if I take
cadmium telluride produced
in Malaysia
installed in Wyoming,
it returns its carbon
within two years.
So it won't drive the
decisions, but it needs
to be an additional factor.
The economics will
drive the decisions.
But if I have a
carbon budget, I start
thinking in numbers
and not in adjectives.
So these things start
to be meaningful.
Because today, investors can
calculate their financial ROI.
They're totally lost
on their social ROI.
What's the climate?
Everything is renewable.
Everything is great.
And we're having a great
party, and everything
is green except the planet.
So only three points that
I want you to remember.
We must engage the market
because the polluters
will be less engaged.
The market lives on metrics.
And to have a good metric, we
need to fix carbon footprint.
So the privilege of knowledge
brings a duty to act.
So let's all act about it.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: So I
have solar panels,
and I pay for wind power.
But by my address, I think I
know Google, at some point,
it would tell you where your
coal is coming from, right,
based on your zip code
or something like that?
So there's a market
in my neighborhood.
I would have Pepco.
It would probably be coal.
But I've opted for wind power.
I've had some people
tell me that's not really
doing anything.
ORY ZIK: So obviously it does.
Having wind is better
than not having wind.
The way it works
today, since once
you have an electron
on the grid,
it doesn't run with an
ID card, you don't know.
So people are loading
wind electricity on their,
let's say, New England IOS, and
then it's assumed to be shared.
I think we can do a
better job with science
for you to allow you to know
your actual carbon footprint.
So you can have a
budget that actually
relates to your activity.
And I think that those numbers
will create extra motivation.
But obviously, your
solar panels and the wind
is a contribution, especially
if the benchmark is coal.
I mean, there's no
argument about that.
It's almost like the lemon
problems in economics,
that more transparency
provides better value.